uh what's the meaning of this whole
thing oh what's the meaning of life
right
Matthew McConaughey
why why are we here
I don't know why
we're here I prescribe to
in a religious sense the restoration
order
and we have to restore
order and religious sense I really I
purchased that and loved that incentive
and loved that
that view
but I don't really know why we're here
but I do know
to go back to the front we are here
that part's inevitable
so now let's flip the script and go to
the why not
just keep living what what are we doing
the base of everything Eric and we can
argue at all at the base of it I can get
all I can come up with is
we'll just keep living man I mean what
else are we supposed to do when we don't
have any idea what to do
whom we know exactly what we want to do
make it matter
even when it doesn't matter that matters
not for what I don't know for the fun of
it that matters
yeah our ability to create meaning and
Beauty in the mundane in the Absurd it's
kind of cool yeah yeah
and then we share with each other yeah
we'll get excited yeah and we create
some pretty cool stuff along the way
I mean I
I say I'm confident enough and I might
be arrogant of me to say but I I I I do
believe
that we're here to each generation have
a small Ascension yeah
or else
what's it for and we're not really sure
what the Ascension is towards just kind
of no
no it's just good job do things to stop
I do think
that
it is
definitely arrogant to think
that we as a species or generation or
people or Humanity are going to reach
the top of the ascended staircase and go
tada
I think that's a I think that is not
only false but I think it's full-hearted
and I think it's his recipe for being
having more angst and and even cynicism
we talked about and unrest and lack of
seeing Beauty and joy in this life while
we're in it
um I think
Life's a verb
live it as best we can hopefully I mean
I don't know sometimes I'm just I don't
have a grand plan man I'm just trying to
connect the damn Dot
I'm confused frustrated I don't know
what I don't feel any gravity or
building or lineage towards what I'm
doing and I'm just like going
[Applause]
what's that Peterson line if you don't
believe in heaven do what you do what
you can to get as far away from hell as
possible sometimes yeah it's a great
line sometimes I'm just trying to like
man just don't don't sink the ship right
now just keep your head above water
maintain to try and hold on
and uh hopefully give yourself a chance
to notice the magic the mystical
I try to do that yeah when it gets rough
because it's there I do believe it's all
around us all the time yeah just are we
on our frequency and do we allow
ourselves to receive it and see it I
gotta tune the radio yeah
because if we look for it too hard we
see false idols and if we don't look at
all become callous and miss it all yeah
it's a fun little life we've got yeah
Matthew uh
I'm a huge fan I think you're an
incredible person
um thank you for all the everything
you've created in this world thank you
for being a unique
human that inspires millions and thank
you for talking today I was nervous but
you made me feel at home I was beautiful
well I felt at home talking with you as
well thanks for sharing that with me
just two Texans that's right
Austin Texas here we go all right thank
you brother thank you